I mean it is extraordinary and he has
decided to finally make a decision on
yevgeny precaution because he was forced
to and come down extremely hard I mean
yesterday we had the FSB saying that
this was an armed Rebellion
um accusing him of effectively treason
uh with an arrest warrant criminal
arrest warrant now we have Putin saying
um you know this will not be stood for
it will be put down reminding the
Russian people of his reasons for
invading Ukraine I'll just quote you
that um you know we must remember that
virtually the entire military economic
and information machine of the West is
directed against us
um Putin said and I think that is just
to reinforce uh why he did it because
pregosian yesterday has said essentially
in his in the last of a numerous
terrains against the Russian armed
forces that the only reason that the war
in Ukraine happened was because
um shoigu the defense minister wanted
extra medals that it was basically to
make the army look good really
extraordinary developments now if
getting pregosian of course he's he's
head of the Mastery of the Wagner
mercenary group who pretty much carried
out the only victory for Russia really
in recent months with back moot
um and he's now claiming that he's
taking control of the Russian military
headquarters in the south of the country
his criticism hasn't been directly of
President Putin though has it it's been
more of the defense Ministry and the
defense leadership but how significant
do you think this could be in terms of
splintering Vladimir Putin's power base
well
hagner now
the kind of power that it did before
ahmud I mean lots and lots of its
Fighters were killed so that's the first
thing down in the south of Russia it
does that's essentially where its forces
are assembled around the krasnada region
and it has its training base which is
incidentally alongside the gru Military
Intelligence they literally hold the
same sort of training base together
around krasnada so that's where the sort
of bulk of his fighting force is we
understand that they have taken control
of military headquarters in rostov and
Don that's the center of the Southern
military command we also have heard
reports that there is a column on its
way to Moscow and that they've taken
control over Onish which is a sort of
city halfway there
um you know that precaution is not one
of the elites this isn't about
splintering the leads this remains if it
is a coup a military coup it remains you
know the Army and uh the mercenary force
uh would fight each other the Army is a
much much bigger Force than yevgeny
plaguardian has so I don't really know
unless he's managed to persuade a lot of
people inside the Army
um to to join him and we have yet to see
whether that's the case how he can
possibly buy force of numbers
um do what he wants to do which is
unseat the top military command and just
very briefly in one of his videos
overnight if gunny pagosian said that
the invasion of Ukraine was based on
lies do you think that will have much
impact with the Russian people
I think that the people have been told
so many different things they have all
formed their views on what uh this
invasion was all about
um I think that they you know this is a
a sort of undermining of the whole
concept of order which is what the
Russians have sort of held on to ever
since the 90s in which Vladimir Putin
has promised to restore and the whole
Ukraine war has upset that to a certain
extent and I think what the Georgian
says some people will believe it some
people won't I mean I think it's
difficult to believe that Ukraine began
because shoego wanted to you know brass
himself up in the eyes of Putin
um but it will certainly add to the
confusion and the uncertainty and the
feeling amongst the Russian people that
this is not going well okay Diana thanks
so much for that Insight thank you